pas une seconde à perdre pour lohan elle
a tout de suite déballer son nouvel
ordinateur et surfent déjà sur internet
prêté par la municipalité de joie ni
pendant un an
il va beaucoup facilité le travail
quotidien de cette collégienne de 12 ans
il est bel et bien j'aime bien parce que
ça va beaucoup m'aider pour les devoirs
ça beaucoup d m'aider pour les
recherches a beaucoup aidé pour tout ce
qui est école et je pense ça va mieux
les alors pense également très apprécié
par sa maman mélodies vis à remettre un
carnet sur quoi employé dans un magasin
hard discount
elle n'a pas forcément les moyens
d'investir dans un nouvel équipement
souvent coûteux on avait un ordinateur
mais nous a lâché cet hiver donc
donc là on avait plus plus d'ordinateur
à la maison plus de tablettes on faisait
tout par rapport à part avec nos
portables
c'est vrai que ça aide beaucoup aussi
mais pas forcément pour tout ce qui est
de voir pour luan ans comme elle ils
sont 140 écoliers du primaire au lycée à
bénéficier de ce prêt à l'origine du
projet un constat lors du premier
confinement avec les cours à distance
apparaît une fracture numérique parmi
les élèves pour la mairie il fallait
agir vite
c'est un travail sur sur l'éducation
parce que on ne peut pas imaginer
notamment dans cette période qu'on ait
des enfants qui décrochent totalement
parce qu'ils ne sont pas parce que leurs
familles n'ont pas les moyens d'être
équipé donc c'est une vraie belle action
de solidarité
reste la question du financement l'état
bien verser 3000 euros de subventions
mais un possible d'équiper tous les
foyers en matériel neuf
c'est donc ici dans les murs de ce
fablab qu'est né un appareil en partie
reconditionnés c'est un micro ordinateur
neuf dans un boîtier qui est imprimé son
imprimante 3d derrière on a ajouté après
du matériel de caillots écran d'occasion
et chaque fois que c'était possible
clavier/souris l'occasion avec un coût
de revient à 120 euros par machine
l'initiative solidaire a déjà inspiré
d'autres communes et sera bientôt
renouveler à joigny